the Joe Rogan experience you could shape
tread which is something that I watched
I went down a rabbit hole the other day
and I went down a plastic surgery facial
reconnect reconfiguration rabbit hole
because of in cells connected to this
conversation we were having earlier
about guys can't get laid these guys
were going to his one doctor there's a
particular doctor I think he's in
Indianapolis and he does facial
reconfiguration like he widens your jaw
he puts implants on your cheeks and jaw
he puts implants on your [ __ ] head so
I get maybe you have a weird-shaped head
maybe your head is shaped like a turtle
or something you have a weird crest on
the top of your head this guy puts
implants under your skin to give you a
nice round head and they had like before
and after this guy was like oh hated my
head no no my head is amazing and I'm
looking at this and I'm going oh my god
like I didn't even think of that but
how's it look it looked way better yeah
but it's what it is is like genetics are
responding to symmetry when you see when
you see poor genetics you see something
weird like weird symmetry Wise's wises
face so narrow why is this chin go down
so low what's weird about him why is it
wise shoulders so narrow wires arm so
long we see a symmetrical or weird
looking people that don't seem to like
it doesn't fit into your idea of what
the accepted breeding genetics of human
beings are right da Vinci cut yeah is
that what it is don't ya yeah it's based
on a there's a certain shape of the face
Beauty the Fibonacci code so were you
thinking oh no I think it's the da Vinci
could if that was a religious thing for
that movie yeah but with within it don't
they talk about the symmetry of the face
I think that's the golden ratio
that's the Fibonacci okay that's the
Fibonacci but yeah this is the guy this
is this guy Wow
so they oh this is an article from cut
of the cut yeah Matt the cut com yeah
that's what this is exactly where I
started so I started on this and I think
it was on Digg or something like that
and then I went from that to all of the
different people that have the
things done and that's something if you
think about it man
if you just get a bum deal you just get
a bit of bad roll the dice you will live
your life with people that don't they
don't want to have sex with you mm-hmm
and this goes back to like the
prostitution thing like what do people
want from those people do they want the
world to be a different place than it
really is because are we operating as if
this world is exactly how it is right
now or are we pretending that the world
is how we'd like it to be one day in a
utopian society because we're doing that
I get you how you're behaving but if
you're looking at the world around you
the way it is and you don't think these
guys should be able to get prostitutes
you're an [ __ ]
I think that kind of boils down with
libertarianism is you know it's whether
or not we are in a evolving utopian
mindset or whether or not we're gonna
just say let people be who they are and
just accept how things are there's a
little bit of that I think I'm on both
sides of that fence sometimes you know
there's there's definitely people that
you just want to leave them alone like
they're not gonna figure it out [ __ ]
them but then there's also people like
we've all met people that have been in a
bad place in their life and turned it
around yeah I don't I don't like giving
up on people
I just don't this isn't it's not human
it's not a human thing to give up on
people right so it's on both sides of
that like part of me wants to go like
figure it out and then part of me wants
to go like we got to help people figure
it out
[Applause]